we live on occupation they confiscate  our lands raid our homes and kill our  people what should we do remain silent  even those who are not fighting the  occupation yet give them some time and  they will fight  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]  we have a lot of people who are killed  or detained there's not one house in the  camp that doesn't have a personal story  for the struggle against the occupation  young children grow up with pictures of  relatives killed by israeli forces this  affects the generations conscious and  subconscious  there's so much symbolism here from the  flags that represent different  palestinian fractions to the fact that  these men are carrying pictures of young  palestinian men who are killed by israel  it's easy  that every one of those men  with israeli occupations